why would
cristiano ronaldo want to be friends
[Music]
[Music]
let's get straight to the point not a
long time it's a chunk thing it might be
a little bit of a bum thing yes
let's watch this video christian
cristiano ronaldo calling khabib on
facetime
let's go watch it
the christians
now the question that needs to be asked
is very simple please let's get to the
point
enough of that let's get straight to the
point why would
cristiano ronaldo want to be friends
with now before we saw them like
you know sending each other love for
instagram so you know i'm watching the
videos and then all right etc beating
each other up
all good but to facetime each other is a
new form of
friendship a new form of bond why this
is where the crux of the mata is
let me tell you guys where my sister is
yeah when we look at khabib now
cristiano ronaldo is famous
himself now someone famous like that
he's not going to go and
you know brush off with you know like i
don't think cristiano ronaldo in his
character and stuff that he's done for
palestine and a lot of poor people as
well and his character he's not somebody
who's going to go and want to you know
stay relevant by you know
talking to uh other people etc like
famous people
there must be a deeper reason why he is
in connection with
habib so much so that they're face
timing each other with his son
cristiano ronaldo was with his son yeah
that is that that is
intimate you know so the question is
this brother and sister yeah
someone even if he wasn't famous
let's ask yourself a question all of us
if habib was not famous
and you just knew about habib you're in
your local community
somebody who's honest praise their salah
respects his mom and dad
talks behind his mom and dad even if his
dad slaps him up
he respects him um he helps the poor he
always talks about allah
yeah he's he's and and many other things
many other things that we can list where
they're praying together and you can see
his companions like a video i did about
his friend
islam i can't pronounce this for him i'm
really sorry no offense yet
so even him doing will do in the
freezing cold
and if you hear about this kind of
circle of friends i would run to these
kind of friends
i would run to them well i'll beg them
please man let me be your friend
even if they were not famous i would say
can i be your friends yeah
now let's put this into cristiano
ronaldo's mind in his mind
he doesn't understand the value of the
prayer and stuff like that he doesn't
know what exactly that is
but there is something fundamental and
this is the reason why a lot of people
who come
to us me mohammed jab mufti men you guys
don't go to talking you never talk about
they think calling to the oneness
they think the religion is made such to
such a low degree
that the way you look the way you act
the how many yanis and arabic language
that you use
determines how knowledgeable you are and
you according to tahit
khabib is one of the best dawah obtain
it
dawah carriers of this
time why because the prophet sallallahu
asallam said
i came for nothing but the perfect good
character
a character imam buhari's mom before he
would send
his son i think he was malik i remember
when he was sent him off the study from
uh a certain scholar he said before you
attain his knowledge
attain his imam ahmed when he would give
talk they say 30 to 40 000 people come
to listen attend yeah
out of them they say thirty thousand
come to observe his good manners
the prophet peace be upon him is
mentioned with his utmost good character
and adam
why why is that brothers and sisters
when it comes to the calling
the worship of one uh um of allah
tawheed
you need to understand that if cristiano
ronaldo so many people even paul logan
logan paul his name is yeah even him
he's talking about like
his character what does that tell you
what does that say please please guys
what does that tell you that tells you
that as an individual as a person
the way you carry yourself it plays a
massive role
the prophet peace be upon him none of
the his enemies called him a liar
none none of them said you're a liar
they would come and give their wealth
and gold for him to look after
so much so that he said to them if i was
to tell you behind this mountain there's
an army coming to kill us would you
believe me they said we know you to be
the truthful
of course we're going to believe you and
he said i'm telling you i'm the
messenger of allah
and you're rejecting me rejecting you're
not calling me but you're rejecting the
message
brothers and sisters this shows you that
our character is
taheed the way we behave is tahid um
um indonesia how did indonesia come to
islam the yemeni traders
they were so honest in their trade trade
deals that people saw and thought
these guys what makes these guys so
excellent in character
so when cristiano ronaldo was looking at
habib
and his sinister respect for his dad and
his mom even if his dad stabs him up
his way carries himself the respect that
he has even to his opponents yeah except
gregor who got
smurked like his habit is he got bounced
off the
floor like a basketball even like you
see for example
that he the the the respect the way he
carries himself
that is something reliable so much so
that non-muslims
they they see that they see them they
might not understand tahit
but when they see that character and
when they see the way they carry himself
even for example when he was uh
fighting um i think was it i can't
remember which king richard however he
was fighting uh to get goods back here
even then when his opponent felt ill he
sent him
a doctor this is the character
this is islam this is what islam is
about
that's why it makes so much sense and
i'm going to end with this why the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
said i came for nothing ever done
except the perfect good character
because good character
having one good character with oneself
having good manners with oneself
how does it start let me tell you
something if one has good manners with
allah
he would never worship any any other
than him he would worship him alone
that's good adam they have a good
character not like the pagan arabs who
ascribe
daughters to allah not like the
christians who ascribe um
divinity to jesus yeah not these other
people who believe in all kind of stuff
that is having bad adam with allah and
once you have good adam with allah you
have good adam with who
with his messenger and how do you have
good ends up with this messenger the
prophet salallahu with him by obeying
the sunnah by following his soon as much
as possible
and once you have good at that with the
messenger the prophet sallam
you have good at death with the people
around you
habib people around you you would treat
them
well be nice and be just be kind the
prophet
allah says in the quran speak up for
truth and justice
even if it's against yourself from kin
meaning even if my
own blood is wrong i'm telling you wrong
this enemy of allah
he's right you're wrong well lie this is
justice teacher so much so
that if i know my friend he musa hijabs
he shunned with me
if i know they wronged someone let's
suppose it's let's suppose it's david
with
the most filthy scum destroyer i have to
speak the truth and say here david was
right i'm so sorry
yes him people scum like him he is right
you're wrong
i'm so sorry because the being comes
first and once you have good at that
with the people you have good
with yourself how does one have good
athlete with yourself you
abstain from sin and say i let me not do
this
it's not worthy of sin committing the
sin against myself brothers and sisters
i want to end this on this knot
alhamdulillah
subhanallah has given us the deen and
may allah make us beautiful in character
that we do not become people who just
repeat like a parrot
that people see our character and see
what
islam inherits within us and see the
beauty in muslims so much
that they say that they say we want to
know about this religion
if people want to know about this
religion because of this terrorist
attack etc where they want to find out
what's this religion about
can you imagine if they said these
muslims when you see them the way they
are
when you're good to your neighbors and
the people around you and if you look up
got this people
i don't know what this dispute of
religion is and that is what will lead
them to the truth
in the oneness i am that no problem
sisters don't forget
these shrines video as well when it
comes to a different angle till next
time
may allah